Resuelve para "x",
5x más 7 mayor que 3x mas 1,
Muy bien,
entonces lo que nos piden es resolver esta desigualdad,
para el conjunto de valores "x" que los satisfacen
¿verdad?
Así que lo que tenemos que hacer
es simplificar el lado derecho,
y eso nos va a llevar a una desigualdad muy conocida, en el sentido de que ya hemos hecho muchos,
muchos, muchos ejercicios de este estilo,
entonces vamos a intentar despejar
la "x" de un lado,
así que vamos a empezar simplificando
el lado derecho
y esto es 5x más 7 mayor que,
y lo que hacemos es distribuir este producto
¿verdad?
Sería 3 por "x",
3x
y 3 por 1 es más 3,
muy bien
entonces para pasar las "x"
todas de un lado
¿Qué tal si restamos de ambos lados 3x?
Podemos restar 3x
de ambos lados
y eso por supuesto,
no cambia el signo de mi desigualdad,
porque solo estamos restando,
entonces del lado izquierdo
¿qué nos queda?
Nos queda 5x menos 3x
que son 2x,
el 7 se queda igual,
y la desigualdad no cambia
solo restamos
y estos se cancelan
¿verdad?
Ese era el punto central de restar,
3x
entonces, si se cancelan
solo me queda un 3
muy bien,
entonces para seguir despejando nuestra "x"
¿qué tal si ahora restamos 7 de ambos lados?
para quitar este estorbo de aquí,
entonces,
¿qué es lo que me queda?
2x más... bueno...
este 2x se queda aquí
los 7 se cancelan
y del lado derecho me quedan,
3 menos 7 son -4
ahora la desigualdad sigue siendo la misma,
porque no dividimos ni multiplicamos
por un número negativo,
ahora bien,
ya para despejar la "x"
necesitamos dividir
ambos lados entre 2,
y como 2 es un número positivo,
esta desigualdad sigue siendo la misma.
Entonces del lado izquierdo
ya me queda "x"
que es mayor que -4 entre 2,
que eso es
-2.
Muy bien,
vamos a ver cómo se vería
esto en la recta numérica,
por ejemplo si tenemos aquí nuestra recta numérica,
que digamos que
aquí anda el -3,
-2, -1, el 0,  el 1, el 2 y el 3
yo creo que  con eso basta,
entonces nos dice que "x" toma
todos los valores más grandes que -2,
entonces,
empezamos en -2
pero, no lo incluimos,
por lo tanto ponemos una bolita abierta, ¿verdad?
Y nos seguimos hacia la derecha
que son
todos los valores reales
que son más grandes que nuestro - 2.
Muy bien, entonces vamos a intentar
algo que funcione y algo que no,
para que más o menos
te convenzas de ello,
por ejemplo,
algo que sí funciona es el 0,
entonces vamos a ver si eso funciona,
5 vamos a sustituirlo aquí,
5 por 0 más 7,
será mayor que
3 por 0 más 3,
pues ojalá sí
¿verdad?
Entonces 5 por 0 es 0
y entonces acá me queda
7 más grande que 3 por 0 es 0 más 3
y sí, sí es cierto que
7 es más grande que 3 ¿verdad?
eso lo sabemos desde la primaria.
¡Muy bien!
Ahora vamos a tomarnos un valor
que no está en este conjunto,
por ejemplo el -3,
muy bien,
vamos a sustituir con -3
y tenemos 5 por -3 más 7
es mayor que 3 por -3 más 3,
vamos a ver si es cierto.
Aquí qué tenemos, 5 por -3 es -15,
más 7 es -8
y esto será mayor que 3 por -3
que es -9
más 3 es -6
y esto por supuesto
que no es cierto,
-8 es mucho más negativo que -6,
por lo tanto, es más chico
entonces, esto no es cierto.
Así que es bueno que -3 no funcionara
porque,
porque -3
no está en nuestro conjunto solución,
intentamos con algo que
sí estaba en nuestro conjunto solución y funcionó,
intentamos algo que no estaba
y no funcionó,
así que eso nos hace sentir
bastante, bastante bien.